[Musique]
c'est une exposition inhabituelle des
sculptures de rodin une douzaine sont
exposées à la galerie capazza dans le
département du cher
cette exposition est le fruit de trois
années de travail en collaboration avec
le musée rodin nous est venue le désir
commandes de rapprocher les oeuvres
d'auguste rodin immense sculpteur et
celle de georges jean claud qui a
énormément marqué l'histoire de la
sculpture au 20e nous aurions dû
inaugurer cette exposition le 28 mars
dernier
malheureusement ça n'a pas été possible
l'événement aurait dû amener à la
galerie des amateurs et des
collectionneurs de toute la france mais
voilà la galerie s'est retrouvé confus
n'est pas de visiteurs pas de vente et
donc pas de rentrées d'argent
problématique pour cette galerie qui
emploie 8 personnes et pour qui lit
habituellement tout redémarre au
printemps nous n'avons pas pu accueillir
le public lors du week-end de pâques que
nous n'avons pas pu entretenir ce lien
qui essaient si cher pour eux comme pour
nous nous n'avons pas pu participer aux
grandes salles ont donc c'est une
période très compliquée évidemment à
chaque crise le marché de l'art souffre
ce fut le cas après la guerre du golfe
en 1991 puis en 2008 avec la crise
financière les conséquences économiques
sont toujours dramatique
le comité professionnel des galeries
d'art estime qu'une galerie sur trois
pourrait fermer dans les 12 prochains
mois
la reprise risque d'être longue et lente
on s'est demandés par l'histoire et par
2 par ces crises on sait que la première
chose qu'on arrête d'acheter c'est
peut-être bien l'art et c'est la
dernière chose qu'on va les gens vont de
nouveau à acheter
[Musique]
les galeries d'art rouvriront leurs
portes le 11 mai prochain
quant aux sculptures de rodin et de jean
claud impassible elles attendent
patiemment le retour des visiteurs